todos escuchamos sobre la tasa de
desempleo todo el tiempo y es obviamente
un indicador económico muy importante
pero lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es llegar un poco más a fondo y
realmente averiguar cómo es calculado
así que voy a empezar y voy a dibujar un
enorme círculo este diagrama representa
a toda la población de eeuu de hecho lo
acabo de ver en google son 304 millones
de personas aproximadamente
quítale ponle luego habrá un subconjunto
porque este diagrama representa a todas
las personas de eeuu incluye a mi hija
de 10 meses
entonces si estamos hablando de
desempleo mi pequeñita no es tan
relevante o al menos aún no lo es y
bueno este es un conjunto de personas
que la oficina de estadísticas del
trabajo considera con una edad
suficiente para preocuparse por aquí
tenemos a los mayores de 16 años y había
aproximadamente 237 millones de personas
pero luego tenemos este otro subconjunto
porque no todo el mundo mayor de 16 años
es necesariamente apto para ser empleado
o quiere trabajar puede estar en la
escuela puede ser militar incluso quizás
se retiró del trabajo entonces buscan un
subconjunto de las personas con la
suficiente edad para trabajar y lo
llaman población activa y lo pondré en
verde mejor no en rosa este subconjunto
en verde es la población activa y bien
en noviembre la cantidad de 154 millones
de personas que lo integran entonces la
población activa tiene 154 154 millones
de personas luego hay un subconjunto de
la población activa que la oficina de
estadísticas del trabajo considera
desempleado y el subconjunto de
desempleados lo haré en naranja a los
últimos números indican más o menos 15
millones de personas
estos son desempleados y bueno todo esto
todos estos números son datos que vi
para noviembre así que la manera simple
como realmente calculan estos números
aunque veremos que hay unas molestias
más de lo que podría decirlas
pero la manera en cómo lo calculan es la
tasa de desempleo es que la tasa de
desempleo es igual al número de
desempleados lo pondré naranja
desempleados / desempleados / la
población activa y está la población
activa está constituida por los
desempleados los desempleados más como
lo hubieras pensado los empleados
empleados más desempleados
entonces para averiguar la tasa de
desempleo donde hay 15 millones de
personas sin empleo así que ponemos 15
millones de personas en el numerador y
en el denominador vamos a poner a toda
la población activa serían 15 millones
de desempleados y luego lo que sea 154
menos 15 cuánto es eso son 139 millones
de personas con empleo así que este
pero de aquí este número es 139 millones
de personas y este otro es 15 millones
de personas suma a ambos y tienes la
población activa 154 millones y bueno
eso sale bastante directo si haces aquí
los cálculos obtienes algo cerca del 10%
pero en lo que me quiero enfocar es en
las definiciones de desempleo y
población activa porque son algo
diferente al menos desde mi punto de
vista y en cómo se usa el término según
las oficinas estadísticas de trabajo
desempleado es alguien que esencialmente
no tiene un trabajo pero quiere uno y la
manera en que miden si quieres un
trabajo es si buscas un trabajo en las
pasadas cuatro semanas así que si yo
estaba tratando de buscar un trabajo y
mandé mi solicitud por todas partes y
luego ya sabes rechazada un par de veces
a pues yo sería considerada desempleada
y esto es algo importante en que pensar
si la economía estuviera mal digamos que
en la semana 1 soy parte de los
desempleados no tengo un trabajo no
tengo un trabajo pero lo estoy buscando
así que soy parte de la población activa
no tengo un empleo pero soy una
desempleada buscando un empleo
entonces supongamos que después de
varias semanas me canso de la situación
y digo caracoles con esto las cosas
están muy mal mejor ni busco trabajo
hasta que todo mejore entonces lo que
sucede es que yo me estoy uniendo a las
personas fuera de la población activa
así que en lugar de estar con la
población activa estoy fuera de no estoy
con este grupo que tiene empleo y si me
tomo cuatro semanas más digamos cuatro
semanas y media en las que no busco
trabajo entro a una nueva clase llamada
de la siguiente manera los trabajadores
ligados marginalmente al mercado laboral
así es todo eso así se llaman pero
llamémosle trabajadores desalentados
estoy con estos cuates los trabajadores
desalentados no estoy en la población
activa así que me estoy quitando tanto
del numerador como del denominador y ojo
de chícharo la economía puede estar tan
mal que si yo me salgo del ámbito
laboral eso puede aumentar la tasa de
desempleo haré un ejemplo con números
sencillos a solo para dejarlo claro
imaginemos el mundo donde todo el
potencial trabajo supongo le podemos
llamar la población adulta y ésta tiene
a tres personas entonces tenemos a tres
adultos tres personas lo suficientemente
grandes para trabajarse y digamos que
hay un subconjunto en este en esta
población adulta a la cual en este
momento consideramos en la población
activa digamos que tiene dos personas
este subconjunto obviamente estoy
utilizando números extremadamente
pequeños pero es bueno porque quiero que
veas la matemática cómo funciona ahora
digamos que una de esas dos personas en
la población activa está desempleado y
este es un ejemplo trivial yo tengo a
dos personas en un subconjunto
y una de ellas está sin empleo la otra
obviamente tiene empleo y tenemos a este
otro cuate adulto que quizás está en la
escuela o jubilado no sabemos muy bien
la situación de este este amigo ahora
digamos que yo soy esta persona sin
empleo sonriendo así bonita y voy en
busca de trabajo pero he sido rechazado
tantas veces y las noticias sobre la
economía son tan malas que decido tomar
un descanso y simplemente paro de buscar
trabajo lo que sucede entonces según las
honorables oficinas de estadísticas del
trabajo es que yo aquí pertenezco
mientras estoy intentando mientras
intento buscar trabajo pero si yo me doy
por vencida si estoy tan desalentado
hasta el grado que paró de buscar
trabajo por más de cuatro semanas
entonces la nueva manera de dibujar este
diagrama de nuestro pequeño país con
tres personas aún tendríamos a tres
adultos pero ahora en lugar de estar
desempleada como yo ya me di por vencida
entonces ya no formo parte de la
población activa
porque no estoy buscando trabajo
entonces la población activa estará
conformada por solamente este cuate que
tiene empleo solo una persona está en
esta en este subconjunto de población
activa y no habrá un subconjunto de
desempleo porque no hay una persona en
la población activa que no tenga trabajo
porque yo ya no estoy en búsqueda de
empleo
entonces yo entro en este otro
subconjunto esta soy yo triste y
solitaria pregunta entonces qué sucedió
aquí es la pregunta a bueno tenía yo una
tasa de desempleo del 50 por ciento uno
dividido entre 21 dividido por toda la
población activa esto es igual de 50% en
tasa de desempleo lo cual es obviamente
un número extremo aunque ahora en esta
otra situación como yo me di de baja de
esta en la población activa por estar
desalentada ahora yo ya no cuento
entonces tenemos el 0% en desempleo y si
superficialmente observamos los números
ya sea porque el numerador o denominador
cambia porque las personas cambian
pueden motivarse
motivarse seguir en la escuela ser amas
de casa a qué sé yo entonces como la
economía estaba tan mal yo brinker fuera
de la población activa y esto es algo no
muy intuitivo entonces como yo hice eso
la tasa de desempleo se ve
superficialmente positiva se fue de
estar en un 50 por ciento en este
ejemplo a un 0% y bueno obviamente en el
mundo real jamás vas a ver este
comportamiento extremo porque tenemos a
más de 3 personas de hecho en este
ejemplo tenemos a 304 millones de
personas ahora bien está en la población
activa es esta noción de estar buscando
empleo en las pasadas cuatro semanas
ejemplo si tu cuñado está durmiendo en
el ático tú lo puedes considerar como un
desempleado pero las oficinas de
estadísticas del trabajo lo consideran
si él no está buscando empleo entonces
él está ubicado con los trabajadores
desalentados